[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen zu Sallys Welt heute
ist ein ganz ganz besonderes Video ich
bin da meine Preußler nicht da und ich
bin heute zeigen was wir oder was ich
den Kindern morgens zum Essen machen
wirklich darf ich was ganz ganz tolles
und zwar unigieri es kommt aus Japan ist
ein riesen Hype momentan überall in
Deutschland es ist eine richtig tolle
Resteverwertung aber auch was richtig
hochwertiges für die Kids morgens zum
Essen Menschen die Kinder haben wissen
was es meistens von Stress ist wenn man
den Kindern morgens das Essen
vorbereitet man überlegt sie mal was
macht man was ist das Kind gerade bei
der Uni hier ist eine ganz ganz tolle
Geschichte ist eine tolle Restaurant
gesagt habe da kann man wirklich ein
paar gesunde Snacks verstecken und die
Kinder liebendes und es macht sogar Spaß
dazubereitung und man kann sogar vorher
an Tanten Tag vorher oder zwei Tage
vorher zubereiten das heißt man nicht
den Stress am Morgen und man kann
preppen nennt sich das also wirklich
vorbereiten und wie das geht das möchte
ich euch in diesem Video auch zeigen und
euch ein paar coole andere Tipps noch
geben wie ich es zu Hause mache ob die
zu 100% richtig sind sei mal
dahingestellt macht es wie ihr wollt
hauptsache ihr macht den Kindern etwas
gesundes und kümmert euch um die Kinder
das ist wichtigste also fangen wir jetzt
mal an mit den Onigiri und da fangen wir
an mit dem Reis für die uniqiri braucht
ihr ungefähr 500 Gramm Klebereis oder
Sushi Reis 600 Milliliter waghäusler
Wasser
50 Gramm Zucker eine Prise Salz und 75
Gramm Reisessig
Sushi reis in einem Sieb mit kaltem
Wasser abspülen bis das Wasser klar ist
den Reis und das Wasser in einen großen
Topf füllen
bei höchster Stufe aufkochen lassen dann
die Hitze des Herdes reduzieren auf
Stufe 2 und mit geschlossenem Deckel 15
Minuten ziehen lassen den Reis in eine
große Schüssel umfüllen damit der
schnell abkühlen kann Reisessig Zucker
und Salz in einem kleinen Topf verrühren
und kurz aufkochen lassen damit sich
Salz und Zucker auflösen können dann mit
dem Sushi Reis kurz durchrühren dafür
mit einem Baumwolltuch abdecken damit
die restliche Feuchtigkeit aufgesaugt
wird so jetzt fangen wir an diese
uniqiri zu formen und der Reis ist jetzt
fertig und ich habe hier Zutaten die ja
wirklich zu Hause habt gesehen jetzt
bisschen spektakulär aus sind aber
definitiv nicht ihr habt die 100% zu
Hause und zwar ich habe hier zum
Beispiel Helden Sesam geröstet oder
schwarzen Sesam dann habe ich hier so ja
den Avocado eine Gurke ein bisschen
Mayonnaise Thunfisch habe ich gefunden
und sogar noch einen Gouda Käse ihr
könnt da wirklich das nehmen was er zu
Hause habt an den Resten und dafür
gibt's diese unigiere gibt's in Japan
wirklich extra Kurse die Eltern weil
diese unigiere auch toll aussehen müssen
war das die Kinder das wirklich so
richtig abfeiern wie es aussieht und es
dann auch essen dafür für die uniqiri
habt eine Möglichkeit und zwar ich habe
mir aus dem Asia Laden so eine unigiri
Box gekauft ist wirklich nichts Großes
nicht teuer kosten die 3 € kostet das
ihr könnt es auch ohne die Box machen
aber ich möchte nur mal zeigen wie es
mit dieser Box ist so dann habe ich
diese Box ist es ganz easy ich nehme
diesen Klebereis und da ist so eine
kleine Schaufel mit dabei ich finde
diesen Klebereis und mach den hier rein
so das macht wirklich zwei drei Mal dann
habt ihr den Trick wirklich rein machen
ihr müsst die Boxen ein bisschen mit
Feuchtigkeit benetzen damit es ein
unigiere nachher besser rausgeht jetzt
mache ich mal einer mit Thunfisch also
ich weiß die Ella sie mag tun Fisch und
dann mache ich oben jetzt einfach wieder
zu
so als Deckel das sowieso eine Tasche
ist und dann tue ich das mit dem
Verdichten
die erste uniqiri ist fertig das heißt
ja wirklich in diese in diese reißtasche
dann Thunfisch reingemacht was meine
Ella auch ganz ganz arg macht und die
Samira sind Gurken natürlich einfach
Würfeln Zack und dann mache ich schon
fürs nächste Uni gehen wieder ganz
einfach hier am Anfang ein bisschen
füllen die Gurken rein
das ist eigentlich muss ich ehrlich
sagen das ist so ein bisschen wie
schwäbische Maultaschen
herrgottscheißern dann nimmt man die das
heißt man packte mit Maultaschen das
mache ich auch und zu den Gurken was
auch toll passt die Ella die mag und die
Samira die mögen beide Käse auch in
Würfel geschnitten und jetzt mache ich
auch diesen Gouda da rein ein paar
Stücke
so und wieder die herrgottscheibe
die japanischen dann wieder den Deckel
drauf
so nicht zu voll machen will ich habe
doch zack bis nächste uni-giri einmal
jetzt ohne giri mit Thunfisch und einmal
mit Käse und Gurke jetzt habe ich hier
z.B das so ein eigenblatt das bekommt
ihr eigentlich überall das riecht auch
leicht fische ich habe immer früher
gedacht das ist mein Fischschuppen hat
ein bisschen Angst davor gehabt aber
sind nicht nur eigen und die sind
wirklich sehr sehr günstig und jetzt
kann man diese eigenblätter nehmen und
einfach hier schneiden so und das tolle
an diesem eigenblatt ist das ist extrem
schnell an dem klebe an dem Klebereis
haften bleiben jetzt nehme ich noch hier
jetzt kann ich das Drumherum liegen so
und das coole ist das Kind kann es auch
jeder nachher festhalten so was man auch
machen kann mit diesen eigenen Blättern
man kann zum Beispiel Augen daraus
machen
da kann man kreativ sein das ist
irgendwie das neue puzzeln sozusagen man
macht hier schöne Augen drauf einmal
hier und dann kann man auch ein Mund
daraus machen
so meine Frau kann es mit Sicherheit
auch schöner was man auch machen kann
man kann zum Beispiel so eine Salami
nehmen und dann mit einer mit einer
Tülle auch zum Beispiel so Bäckchen
ausstechen oh gott ist das süß so und
dann könnte man zum Beispiel auch einen
brombeer nehmen und aus und eine brombe
entfernen daraus eine Nase machen
guck dir mal wie mein Onigiri aussieht
richtig cool also guck mal und jetzt
sind die Kinder und die feiern das
richtig ab die sagen komm aus dem Papa
mir gemacht hat und hier zum Beispiel
Sony Gerät so als als zum Fest heben
oder kann man wirklich alles rein machen
was man natürlich auch mit der uniqiri
machen kann man kann sie auch hier eine
Avocado zum Beispiel machen ist auch
eine ganz ganz coole Geschichte in der
Avocado reinmachen oder süß mit einer
Mango und das was meine Samira und meine
Ella auch mag ist man Sojasoße man kann
so ein kleines bisschen Sojasoße
reinmachen und glaub mir eure Kids sind
damit in der Schule der absolute
superheit wenn ihr das haben möchtet
oder ihr könnt zum Beispiel auch hier
mit Sesam ein paar Sommersprossen drauf
Mann auch richtig süß aus wenn ihr zu
viel zu Hause jetzt nicht diese Boxen
hat diese
Unboxing zu besorgen wie ich sie nicht
teuer dann könnt ihr das alles auch eine
uniqiri auch mit einer Frischhaltefolie
machen zu 100% zu Hause die Zutaten
findet ihr wirklich überall die gibt's
inzwischen überall ihr könnt die
Frischhaltefolie machen und dann macht
die genau das gleiche wie ich vorher mit
mit dieser mit der Schale gemacht habe
ich einen Löffel
macht euch ein bisschen Reis drauf
so dann macht es ein bisschen zu und
dann gibt er dem Reis einfach die Form
die er gern hättet so jetzt mache ich
noch mal mit Thunfische weil ich weiß
mit Thunfisch schmeckt richtig lecker da
mache ich auch was cooles ich nehme ein
bisschen Mayonnaise dann nehme ich den
Thunfisch tut es ein bisschen vermixen
und das sind wirklich ihr könnt da
wirklich rein machen was ihr wollt was
die Kinder mögen dann ist ein bisschen
Thunfisch drauf nicht zu viel machen
bisschen Klebereis wieder drauf baue ihn
so zu und ich muss ehrlich sagen ich
mache das wirklich auch selber
vielleicht zu zweit oder zum dritten Mal
überhaupt jetzt mache ich es wieder so
und jetzt fahre ich jetzt wie ein
unigiere das meiste ich mache es erst
rund Japaner braucht dafür 5 6 Jahre ich
brauche dafür vielleicht fünf sechs Tage
man kann es probieren ich glaube da muss
ein bisschen was lernen das sieht jetzt
nicht aus wie so ein uniqiri aber das
kann aussehen wie ein Panda Augen
und dann mache ich noch eine Blaubeer
rein cool oder sieht aus wie ein
Einbrecher kenn ich irgendwoher das wäre
zum Beispiel und ich muss mal essen
Hammer
lasst eure Fantasie wirklich frei laufen
wirklich das was im Kühlschrank gehabt
und jetzt kommen wir zur fertigen
Lunchbox von der Ella und von der Samira
so und für Samiras Box mache jetzt ganz
ganz cool mache ich einen Salat rein die
ohne die ich gemacht habe
für die Samira dann eine Gurke Sie Marc
Gurken dann ein bisschen Obst und zwar
ein paar Himbeeren Blaubeer mag sie auch
ganz arg
und noch mal zwei karötchen so die
Lunchboxen sind jetzt fertig für die
Kinder das heißt der Tee und die
unigiere sind fertig so sehen sie aus so
werden sie die Kinder auch mitnehmen
macht auch da wirklich gar keinen Stress
es ist nicht meine Intention Papa des
Jahres zu werden absolut nicht aber hier
haben sie irgendwas nerviges im Teil
Obst ein Teil Gemüse ein paar
Kohlenhydrate gerade hier mit dem Reis
alles perfekt die Kinder werden es
lieben das ist auch was fürs Auge und
das könnt ihr machen ja und das wäre
jetzt das Ende vom Video hat mir richtig
Spaß gemacht euch da was zu zeigen
vielleicht ist ein Inspiration auch für
euch zu Hause
macht's gut ihr backforellen liebe Grüße
aus waghäusern ciao
[Musik]